[Music]
pop quiz how many megabytes do you think
it takes to stream an episode of cobra
kai
to your phone how about uploading a tick
tock listening to a podcast if you're
like most people
you have no idea and yet when you go in
to buy a cell phone the sales rep will
present a bunch of different data plans
to you as if
you know how many gigs you're going to
use over the next 30 days
that's why most people end up going with
what seems like the safest option
unlimited data sounds good right i mean
i use my phone a lot and i don't want to
count megabytes
sure it's more expensive than the capped
plans but at least i'll know that i
won't run out of data in the middle of a
road trip or an important video
conference before you make that
call there's a few things you should
know about those unlimited
data plans it's data data data
data
[Music]
first unlimited plans are not exactly
unlimited
they usually still have a data cap and
once you go over that
your speeds will slow down depending on
how busy the network is
secondly many carriers will sometimes
give capped accounts higher speeds than
unlimited ones
the reason is that when capped customers
go over their limit
they can be charged extra so there's
incentive for the carrier to let them
rip through their data as quickly as
possible
unlimited customers have already paid
everything they're gonna pay
so why make it easy for them to use data
it's kind of like an all-you-can-eat
buffet that deliberately uses
small plates to keep the diners from
eating too fast
third and this is the big one you
probably don't need that much data
anyway according to a 2018 study the
average usage by unlimited data
customers was only
6.1 gigabytes per month that may seem
strangely low but it's because you only
use your mobile
data when you're not connected to a
wi-fi network and wi-fi is everywhere
at home at work on campus at the gym and
the coffee shop
sure there's a small number of people
who might rely on mobile data
like if you do a lot of business on the
road or you don't have broadband at home
and
use your phone to stream movies but for
most of us
mobile data represents a small
percentage of our overall usage
so then why are most of us subscribed to
unlimited plans
mainly because that's what the service
providers want us to do
unlimited plans are heavily promoted by
the big carriers
often bundled with phone discounts and
free subscriptions to streaming
platforms
in fact you have to dig pretty deep into
their websites to find
any alternatives and most of the big
wireless companies have started making
their capped data plans
pre-paid only which means you have to
pay for a whole year of service up front
they really want you to choose unlimited
and why wouldn't they
with the cheapest premium network access
plan
offering 50 gigs a month that means the
average customer
is using less than a quarter of the data
they're paying for
that would be like paying for 100
gallons of gas every month even though
you
only use 20 and you don't get credit for
the gas you didn't use
it goes right back to the oil company
now if you happen to be one of these
people who
actually uses 50 to 100 gigabytes of
mobile data a month
you might want to cut down on your
screen time but you are getting a
really good deal that's way less per
megabyte than the average rate
but only because all those other
customers are paying for megabytes
they're not using
essentially subsidizing your low price
this is similar to the business model of
many gyms and fitness clubs
most of their members barely use the
services they pay for
which keeps the price low for those who
work out regularly
so how much money can you actually save
by foregoing unlimited data plans data i
think it's time to
run the numbers
one year ago kevin got a new phone from
one of the major
wireless carriers and the sales rep
strongly encouraged him to go with an
unlimited plan kevin travels a lot for
work and relies on his phone when he's
on the road so he figures
he's probably a slightly above average
data user
he opts for the mid-tier option 50 gigs
of data without slowdown for 75 dollars
a month
plus fees and taxes a year later kevin
happens to check his data usage and
finds that he used on average about 7.5
gigabytes a month
only 15 of the total he's paying for at
first
he thinks that can't be right but then
he starts remembering
all the places he typically uses his
phone airports cafes hotels convention
centers all with wi-fi
not wanting to spend money on something
he doesn't use he
digs through the carrier's website and
finds that they have an
eight gig prepaid plan for only 25 a
month
if you pay for the whole year up front
that's 300
now versus 900 over the course of the
year
an easy decision for kevin who happens
to have enough cash on hand
there is one drawback to kevin's plan at
only 8 gigabytes a month
he will have to be a bit more careful
about how he uses his data
fortunately there are some simple
options in your phone settings
to minimize usage outside of wi-fi like
turning off push notifications
automatic app updates and gps when
you're not using them
kevin also decides to bring a book with
him when he travels so he'll have
something
else to do with his downtime than doom
scrolling through twitter
and that brings us to another major way
your cell phone is ripping you off
not by stealing your money but your time
almost every app and social platform on
your phone
is explicitly designed to keep you
engaged well past the point of any
benefit
let's be honest just staring at the
clouds is probably a better use of your
time than arguing with your cousin on
facebook or
fueling your fomo on instagram if
switching from
unlimited to prepaid will save you money
and
motivate you to cut down on unproductive
distractions
i'd call that a win-win over the last 20
years cell phones have gone from a
luxury
to a necessity but unlike most other
utilities the way we're charged for
wireless service is inherently vague
as someone who likes to keep track of
what i'm getting for what i'm paying
i hate that fortunately you don't have
to stumble around in the dark
check your data usage look into
alternate companies and plans it
may take a bit of digging and a fair
share of discipline but when it comes to
your cell phone
you not your carrier should be the one
making the calls
and that's our two cents data it's data
it's data okay it's not the star trek
character
it's data hey guys it's us again so so
many of you leave such really wonderful
thoughtful
comments questions and we just wanted to
take a little time at the end of the
video
to address them miriam korver hello she
put that this video is applicable to my
situation pretty specifically i pay
850 in rent which is over
half my income oh that's tough
we generally recommend trying to keep
your housing at
under 25 of your income but 850
is not a high rent i mean that's an
affordable rent
to me this kind of drives home the point
of you know this viewer and if anyone's
in this situation
doesn't necessarily need to just do
better themselves
we as a society need to do better for
people who are in situations like that
yeah and that there's a really great
book about this whole issue called
evicted
actually won a pulitzer prize his main
thought is that
we need to basically expand these
voucher programs for really low income
families that will
cap how much of their income can go to
their basic needs and he said like
something like 70
of the households who are going through
eviction have children
eviction does happen in poverty but it
can also
create poverty this is a
a good one to leave on so daniel grooms
put
it's important to keep asking why until
you
actually reach the bottom of the issue
why can't landlords make money off
cheaper housing why won't communities
allow
low-income housing to be built why
communities want to allow this
you know a lot of us are scared that's
something we need to work on that's
something that we
we shouldn't just be okay with that
that's just the way things are
because that can change and it doesn't
need to be that way so ask
questions that you would like us to look
at and maybe even answer
in our next episode yes indeed see you
later bye bye
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
[Music]
if you want to learn more about how
fitness clubs get people to pay for
things they don't use
check out our video the hidden costs of
joining a gym